hey everyone
welcome to this week's live session
today's topic is tips to learn python
where we will discuss how to learn
python in a right way
but before we begin i'd like to thank
our viewers for tuning in
and actively participating in these
sessions
let's wait for a while for a few more
people to tune in
also we have a dedicated team here to
answer all your queries so if you have
any questions
let us know in the chat section and we
will get back to you as soon as possible
all right i see a few more of them have
joined
so this session will be about today's
topic which has
tips to learn python so let us begin
first we will understand why python is
so popular
after that we will go through the
important tips that you should have to
follow
while learning python in the end we will
have a look at the current industry
trends of
python developer in the tech industry so
without further ado
let's get started why python
so why exactly python is so immensely
popular
let us have a look first reason is
python is easy to learn
less time and resources are required for
a beginner to learn and start
implementing python
if we compare this to programming
languages such as java
or c plus plus the next reason is python
is cross-platform cross-platform or
platform
independent is one of the programming
language features that allows a
developer to learn
intermediate code on different operating
systems
the third reason is python has hundreds
of libraries
python's library collection is huge and
allows developers to use pre-written
code
saving time when developing a new
program and finally
python has excellent community support a
python developer stuck in a piece of
code
should not be concerned about receiving
relevant support
to start with while most languages lack
documentation
guides and video tutorials python has
this in
abundance so now moving ahead we will
understand
few tips to learn python also
python can be used for building small
services as well as
large enterprise applications now we
will move ahead and
understand tips to learn python at a
bare minimum
you and your resource must cover the
fundamentals
without understanding them you will have
a hard time working through complex
problems
projects or use cases examples of
python's fundamentals include
variables and types lists dictionaries
and sets basic operators string
formatting
basic string operations conditions
loops functions list comprehensions
classes and objects after covering all
the fundamentals
you should establish a goal for your
study
before you start learning python
establish a goal
for your study you will know what
learning material to focus on
or skim through as it pertains to your
goals
for example if you are interested in
becoming a machine learning
engineer you should refer to only that
relevant
material there are several tech
industries that use
python for development machine learning
and ai
web development game development and
internet of things once you have
established your goal
you should also have a look at relevant
python libraries that helps you reach
your goal
there are hundreds of libraries that are
used by python developers
and different domains these libraries
make your life easier
since they reduce manual workload and
wrap code for specialized tasks
these libraries make your life easier
since they reduce
manual workload and wrap up the code for
specialized works
there are many popular libraries out
there for example
django for web development pandas for
data analysis
and many more some of the most popular
python libraries
are tensorflow for machine learning
flask
for web development scrapy for web
scraping
buy game for game development after
doing all this
now you are ready to make and work on
python projects
on your own it is very important to
apply
what you learn while learning each
python concept
making projects as you progress is
highly recommended
since it will make you a good coder and
expand your portfolio
don't expect to make industry standard
projects from the start
but improve upon them as you learn more
some of the interesting ideas that you
can base your projects on
are number guessing web scraper
calculator searching and sorting
tic-tac-toe game
consistency is really important no
matter what you learn
or do it is not realistic for anyone to
expect to become a developer within a
week
except be consistent and work towards
short-term goals and reach those goals
within a set time frame remember
two hours daily for a month are always
going to be more productive
than cramming everything within a week's
time
now moving ahead let's have a look at
python industry trends and
ultimately add the scope of a python
developer
in the last several years python has
seen enormous growth in demand
with no sign of slowing down the
programming language her ranking site
pypl has ranked python as the number one
programming language
with a considerable popularity gain in
the year 2019
as well as in the year 2020.
also python has surpassed java and
become the second most popular language
according to github repositories
contributions
machine learning is probably the most
popular field
in the tech industry right now python
because of its variety of libraries and
the preferred language
for performing machine learning tasks
libraries like numpy pandas tensorflow
are
widely used in machine learning and
artificial intelligence
so if you are into machine learning and
artificial intelligence
python should be the right language for
you
software engineers with python skills
are offered better salaries across the
globe
average python developer salary in india
is
7 lakhs 55 497
per annum average python developer
salary in the united states of america
is 79 395
american dollars there you go we hope
you are now motivated enough to start
your learning journey
and are ready to keep working on getting
better at bison
we also have a python youtube playlist
that covers everything
from very basics to advanced python
concepts
the link is added in the description and
with that
we have reached to the end of this video
hope you liked it
think we miss anything important let us
know in the live chat
or in the comment sections below if
you're watching this later
thank you for
you